Joining me today is British author,
journalist and political commentator
Douglas Murray.
He is also the associate director of the
Henry Jackson Society and associate
editor of the spectator.
Douglas,
welcome to the Rubin report.
Very good to be with him to see you in
person.
I don't know how we haven't done this in
person yet.
They haven't been in La.
It's.
Yeah.
What in God's name are you doing?
Living anywhere else besides la?
Uh,
well it's,
it's actually not my favorite bit of
America.
I have to say I find it slightly
unscented and routines because also
because I don't drive.
So La is sort of hell because you can't
walk anywhere.
Well I know you're not making that up
because you were stuck on a plane for
about four hours last night.
You arrived at like 2:00
AM.
Then we tried to send a car to get you
this morning.
That took some time if it's me being
difficult.
No,
I actually,
I used to watch the three films before
the plane even took off last night.
She's New York.
Anything good?
No awful films.
They're all bad or mad?
Almost always bad.
Do you feel you're at your intellectual
best right now because you didn't get
much sleep?
The you're ready to do that defends our
mangers.
You want to be.
Well,
I've got some pretty rigorous questions
right here.
Uh,
but I think that's an interesting way to
kick off because you are somebody that,
you know,
everything that I,
that I see you.
Right.
And the events that you speak at and,
and the talks that you've given all that
stuff,
I mean you have to be at your
intellectual best pretty much all the
time.
Uh,
I don't know if you feel you always are,
but,
but what kind of pressure does that put
you under just to be,
to be one of the people that,
you know,
you have to have a cohesive set of
thoughts and be able to defend them all
the time.
I'm not sure you have to have the keys,
but I tell you what I mean.
I don't admire or envy politicians for
having to have the thing of having to
turn up,
say the right thing.
Never be off message and all that sort
of thing.
I kind of feel,
you know,
I'm a writer,
I can,
I can have bad days,
uh,
I can change my mind on things.
I can nuance things,
texture things or I can be garbled one
day and um,
you know,
nobody says,
oh my God,
he's a total train wreck.
I don't know.
I don't know if they did.
Oh,
when we care.
But.
Well,
it's funny you say that because right
before we started we were talking about
social media a little bit when you were
saying how you don't respond that often
or,
or paying that much attention to that.
I'm not on Facebook,
I'm on twitter.
I use twitter as a way to communicate to
the few people who can,
you know,
anything I write or appear on.
Um,
but I don't talk to the world as it
were.
Um,
I don't think it's doable.
I think it drives people mad.
Seeing some of the least,
you know,
Bernard really promising minds.
My generation slightly wracked by social
media.
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
you wouldn't,
you wouldn't seek out people to shout at
you in the street,
so you wouldn't.
If they did say,
come
over here,
say this more regular basis and do it
when I wake up and turn over in the
morning and turning my phone on.
Yeah.
So I do think that people have to find a
sort of reasonable way to live in this
strange,
strange world,
which is even stranger in our hail is
now.
Yeah.
Well it's,
it's much stranger in La and we are
going for dinner tonight.
I'm going to show you how we can get,
you know,
what's weird in La.
I'm gonna I'm gonna show you tonight.
Um,
tell me a little bit.
So we've done this once before and it
was about two years ago and I had just
started doing an interview show and we,
we talked about a lot of the problems
that we both had with the left and the
rise of Islam in some of that we're
going to cover here.
Uh,
but I thought maybe we could just talk
about a little bit about your history
first and what kind of brought you to be
one of the,
one of the few people that is so
outspoken on some of these issues.
What,
what made you care about the free speech
stuff about what's happening in the
west,
all of this stuff,
when did that really spark in you?
Um,
it's hard.
I mean,
these things are easier to recognize
other people than they are in yourself.
Um,
I've written about a lot of different
things in my life.
I started writing very young.
I became a,
became a published author as it were.
I wrote my first book when I was 18,
came out when I was 19 or 20 I think.
And um,
that was on literature,
um,
and,
or literally figure.
And then I started writing about
politics and the one thing which,
uh,
somebody once said to me about me as
well that I thought it was probably
somewhere near the truth was that
somebody once said that I had a very low
tolerance threshold for lies.
And I think there is something in that.
I,
I genuinely,
maybe it all wear out at some point,
but I'm just overdose as it were on
lies.
But I,
I just,
I find,
um,
I,
I don't like being told lies and I don't
like it about historical things.
That's my first book is partly about,
I think it has sort of set of historical
misunderstandings that had happened in
relation to the figure I was writing
about and I wanted to correct them.
And then in politics,
of course,
if you have a low tolerance for lies,
maybe it's just not the right area.
So that was my next question.
Maybe you picked it,
not because I got into surfing or
something I didn't know,
but,
but policy,
politics and political lives,
um,
uh,
galvanizes me.
And I suppose the other thing is that
I'm not a political,
not,
I'm not,
I don't really care who's running in
that district for which party and which,
you know,
party they voted for four years ago.
Now I sort of thing is interesting.
It's not what I spend my life feeling
particularly oppressed or,
you know,
enamored with.
But I do.
Um,
I do think that if you care about the
culture in the widest sense as I do,
then you've got to be interested in
politics,
uh,
you,
you've got to take some attitude towards
it and they say in order that you
further your political goals or
something if you want to do that,
you should really be a politician.
But I think in order to try to safe
guard coach,
I mean,
I don't even mean the coats.
I mean really to safeguard the practice
of culture and then that's what politics
seems to me to be very largely for.
Um,
I'm quite interested in taxation and not
very interested in it.
I just want the circumstances to be
right for the culture to thrive.
Yeah.
So when people say,
Oh,
you know,
I'm not a political person or something
like that,
I,
I hate that phrase because it really.
What are you actually saying?
You're like,
you're either pretending that you're
above it or you somehow don't need it.
And yet politics,
you're right.
It's about creating the conditions so
that you can do all of the other things
you care.
I think what people,
what a lot of people mean when they say
that is,
um,
I'm not a party person,
I'm not gonna bore on about the Labor
Party Organ Soda Party of the Democrats
or Republicans.
I think that's what what people mean,
but in any case,
a lot of people who said that sometime
ago don't see that anymore.
In fact,
that maybe the more they said in the
past they weren't a politics person,
the more now the shrieking and jibberish
and storming.
Yeah.
Do you think there's a danger in that?
So we had all these people that,
you know,
whatever,
that whatever that meant to them,
they weren't politics people,
but now everybody's shrieking and
screaming and everyone's in the part of
it that you just said,
that doesn't really do it for you.
That piece of the day to day race horse
stuff.
And that's why I try to focus on the
philosophical stuff because [inaudible]
who's running for this or all of that
stuff.
Yes,
it's important at some level,
but it's the bigger picture stuff that I
think really matters.
Yes.
And,
uh,
you know,
to a great extent in your country and
your mind,
uh,
there is a type of person now who I
think has got politics all the wrong way
around.
I mean,
maybe it is,
as I say,
people who didn't pay much attention to
it in the past,
but there are people who are now,
I think putting onto politics.
I'm an amount of weight that it can't
bear.
Yeah.
It's about their entire existence as it
were.
And I wouldn't want that to be the case,
uh,
at all.
I mean,
I,
uh,
you know,
I had with a colleague sometime ago,
sort of informal competition of the
Conservative Party won the 2015 election
in Britain.
Had An informal competition to say,
now what's the nuttiest thing anyone's
said?
And the best was his woman at the
Guardian who wrote a column saying that
basically she cried herself to sleep
every night and she woke up in the
morning crying and she,
sometimes she stopped crying.
She woke up because you thought,
oh my God,
I've had a nightmare.
No,
it's true.
And then she burst into tears again.
That person shouldn't really be in the
community,
it should,
they,
but if I,
I,
you know,
I have views.
I was on here,
I want to win and at any one time which
party I'd vote for,
but,
but I cannot imagine any scenario in
which I became such a jittering wreck
that I just wept all the time or because
she might not have been telling the
truth.
Is this con or thought it wise to say to
people,
that's the state I'm in.
Right,
right.
Well,
it shows
her victimhood.
She's such a victim.
She can't sleep the best is when you see
the Huffington post or one of these
pieces probably in the Guardian to where
it's not just them that are carrying
their children.
Waking Up,
having nightmares about trump.
My three year old's having a nightmare
about drumming.
What can I,
what should I tell my three year old?
But now he's asking about trump.
And again,
I know I tend to go to sleep.
You know,
it's so funny,
I,
I tweeted this out a couple months ago,
but when we're in the middle of the
election,
uh,
you know,
all these articles are getting ready to
kick kick how trump is affecting kids.
This one thing.
So I asked,
I asked my,
my,
at the time,
I think he was five or six,
my nephew,
I said,
what do you,
what do you know about Donald Trump?
He looks at me,
he's like,
he has bad hair and a red tie.
And I was like,
that's what again,
that's what a kid would think.
Alright.
So I want to talk about your book,
but I thought before we get into that,
I want to do a little bit more on just
sort of language in general and the free
speech thing.
So when you come to America,
because we have some extra protections
for now,
at least on free speech that you guys
across Europe don't have.
Do you feel an extra degree of freedom?
You don't strike me as someone that ever
bites your tongue,
but when you come here and know that we
have such a great free or do you see
something a little different here
perhaps?
I think you do.
I mean,
I,
I think you just got to separate out
between the,
what your legal rights are as it were
and what the actual practice is these
days.
Yes.
Legally.
I mean I'm,
there's nothing I say that it's illegal
in Britain or Europe.
Um,
uh,
and so I don't particularly feel,
you know,
and he sort of freer to say anything
here because there's nothing I would say
here that I wouldn't say there and vice
versa.
Um,
it's true that the,
the having a,
an amendment to our constitution that
she writes this in the law is a useful
thing to have a,
we of course don't even have a
constitution in Britain which has its
own advantages and problems.
But,
uh,
but I think these things have to be
slightly divorced from the reality of
the practice as is at the moment and at
the moment,
I think your probably in a worse
situation than we are in Britain or
Europe in relation to speech,
um,
mainly because of a generation of people
who are growing up and the most
privileged generation in history who,
um,
seemed to think that speech is violence
and that in response to violence you
should be violent.
And if you make that leap,
then the response or somebody speaking
is the them and a or shutting down or to
burn a building or to get them killed or
whatever you want.
And I see that all the time,
all over the place.
Somebody I know in Holland who died just
a couple weeks ago,
a lot of people in the press have him
demonizing him and his house was
attacked two nights ago in Amsterdam.
And uh,
there's lots of that going on.
Loads of loads of target selection.
Um,
and uh,
and I think,
I think all this is very,
very worried,
but I do think that in general,
you,
you seem in America to make terrible
generalization,
to be slightly further down the road of
certain manias about this.
Um,
it seems to embed itself more this idea
of being wounded or even hurt by,
by,
by words and,
and.
Yeah,
and you've got all of the saw stuff
slightly worse I think.
Yeah.
Do you think that may be just that in
and of itself could be just a cultural
thing that Americans kind of scream
about things more?
We're a little more hysterical.
You guys are a little more polite.
I was asking a friend in New York about
this the other day.
Uh,
it's,
I wonder whether the,
you know,
that thing that you always hear in
America,
this is the most important election of
our lifetime.
Every single one.
And it's always,
I mean,
by the way,
I'm,
I'm fascinated by the language
hyperventilation in this country.
And I was fascinated by that moment
before the last election.
My Bill Maher said,
look,
we called,
uh,
um,
senator mccain,
the massage.
And so we were just doing it,
try to get him,
and we were like,
no,
it wasn't.
And then we did.
They tell on him and then we realized he
wasn't really.
Romney wasn't really misogynist,
but now this guy is.
So I'm fascinated by this thing of
basically a lot of sort of chickens
coming home to roost in some ways you,
you kept running the language down and
now you're in this position.
But I said to this friend in America the
other day,
maybe the,
the,
the as it were,
the hyperventilation of politics is one
of the ways in which you keep your
democracy fresh.
We maybe you have to live with that
pitch.
I mean,
I wouldn't particularly want to live at
it myself all the time,
but perhaps the kind of this is always
the most important moment ever is
important for this democracy.
Maybe it's better than sort of doesn't
really matter or never going to be as
good as that.
Again,
that's a real.
I'm going to ruminate on that a little
bit because I think you can argue it
both ways.
I think.
I mean it's what you're saying.
I can see a problem with that level of
hysteria all the time.
And you're right when,
when Bill Maher said that,
oh yeah,
yeah.
The left was saying all these horrible
things about mccain.
We did it about mccain.
We did about romy.
This is the real one.
Well,
you've cried wolf to the point now that.
What did you expect to happen in an odd
way?
Is that a,
is that a pro trump argument?
Strangely,
like he was of course what was going to
happen here.
You know what I mean?
Like you tried it with you try to have
some decent sorta center right people,
but of course you're going to get this
then,
right.
Maybe,
maybe I'm,
I'm,
I'm resistant myself to the,
um,
to introducing Donald Trump told me any
discussion almost always derails after,
um,
after almost everything that happens in
the UK in recent,
the last year or so,
say,
well,
how will this affect Donald Trump?
Get stopped talking about to say allow
other things in the world to exist as
well.
So you're saying when,
I think you're mayor of London was
saying,
we don't want trump to come here,
you'd be okay if trump showed up.
Right.
I think that's just saying that Donald
Trump has made an official visit to
Paris.
Yeah.
He's made official visits to Germany to
a toilet.
So quite a lot of allied countries by
now.
I think.
Yeah,
I think it's outrageous and I think
people should protest if they want to
protest.
But um,
uh,
and I remember the protests against
George W dot Bush when he came to London
and during his presidency and there was
some very,
very vehement protests.
Um,
but I don't mind people protesting,
of course it's a right,
but I just,
I think this attempt to say,
I mean our most important ally and
particularly an important time in our
national history in Britain when we need
to be re reforming our alliances and
renewing them to say f off to the
president of your closest allies seems
to me to be very,
very unwise as well as rude.
Yeah.
Is it one of those things where it's
just,
it's just the easy answer,
you know,
just all that I'm here with a will,
it shows how good we are.
Don't let him hear,
but actually what you do,
you're actually do damage to probably
the most important relationship that
these countries have.
Some.
I mean when the mayor of London says we
don't want him in London.
Yeah.
Well while he's in Paris in Berlin,
like what have you achieved the best you
will,
you'll damage among other things,
the economic relations between Britain
and America.
So Nice work,
Mr.
Nice work.
Right?
Right.
Uh,
all right,
so we're almost,
we're almost at your book.
So I thought this is the good transition
here.
I was listening to,
I think it was,
you're not your last discussion with Sam
Harris,
maybe the one before that.
And you were guys were talking about
language and sort of the slow erosion of
what's happening in the west and the
rise of Islam.
A lot of the,
the key stuff that we all kind of talk
about and you were talking about how
we're going to be arguing about gender
pronouns as all of our rights are going
to be taken away from us.
You said it far more eloquently and with
some better adjectives.
Uh,
but I thought it was a really
interesting point that our,
our eye is not on the prize in that
we're not focusing on what's really
important and we're worried about things
that are not to say trans gender rights
aren't important,
but they're not the big picture stuff.
How important is all of that?
Focusing on the right things?
I think it's crucial.
I mean,
um,
and people can be interested in whatever
they like,
but I also have the right to tell him I
think they're wasting their lives.
I'm agender pronouns.
All of this sort of thing.
These,
this is there is,
by the way,
behind all this,
something very strange.
I started to notice,
um,
that,
uh,
all of the fascinating things about
this,
one of the ones that interest me most is
why you get this,
this,
this introduction to almost every
discussion is if we as human beings are
sorta solvable things,
I find this fascinating.
Most of the Trans stuff is you identify
that you're the wrong gender at an early
stage.
By the way.
I'm very suspicious about all that.
But,
um,
I think can think of a lot of a feminine
young men who shouldn't have drugs even
encouraged towards them.
Yeah.
When you say that you mean you're
suspicious of,
of the way we're treating them or have
the sort of psychological
psych,
the psychological thing in general,
but let's say in a case when somebody
actually does genuinely feel that they
are in the wrong body and that there is
just this awful thing in it.
As in so many other discussions at
moment of.
And if you mix that you,
um,
be on,
you'll be right.
And um,
I think,
no,
no.
Once you sort that out,
you'll face all the same problems
everyone else faces in their lives.
And maybe some new ones,
but,
um,
this,
this is,
I hear this in the race discussion in
America.
I hear it in the gay discussion in
America,
in,
in a whole set of them.
It's as if it's as if,
if we get the formula right,
I said,
I,
I just think this is a fascinating
mistake.
Um,
I don't think we live our lives as
solved or solvable beings and um,
and we are,
we are engaged as me in ticketing in
this society,
in America in this strange attempt to
sort of get it the minute shy,
right?
And apart from being deeply navel
gazing,
it seems likely to me that,
that we may be missing all the really
important things that are going on.
I will have this sort of haunting view
always that we all feel like we've
really sorted out every aspect of Lgbtq
rights just as China becomes the most
important power in the world.
Very interesting.
Right.
Interesting.
I think it's a fascinating piece because
I was gonna ask.
I was going to talk a little bit more
about this at the end,
but you're gay and I,
I asked you in our last interview right
at the end,
by that fact alone,
how much does that give you an extra
sensitivity to all of the other things
that you're talking about?
You have a vested interest.
You and I,
and I think all of us,
I think all humans altogether have a
vested interest in keeping the West
arrived.
But I think as a gay person,
it's particularly important that the
last places of tolerance in western
thought are kept alive.
Yes.
I have to say my own case.
That's not particularly a galvanizing
thing.
I have to say.
Um,
I mean I think being gay is kind of
boring as a subject in a way because
certainly for my generation,
I mean we sort of came out,
came out and buy your $20.
Who wants to keep going on about that a
little bit and that,
why people did before.
But um,
you is not a career or life as it were
and just being a gay,
I mean,
not a full time occupation.
Only so many of us can be in reality TV
know there's only so many fashion gigs
on Bravo and um,
I,
so I've never,
never.
It's never particularly influenced by
politics and in fact,
I may have said this to you before,
but I'm,
I'm,
I'm generally very opposed to the idea
of politics being about what am I,
myself and how can I get the world to
most accommodate itself towards me.
Um,
I think it's a mistake having politics
should be a search for some kind of
truth or the best arrangement that
allows the truth to occur.
And you know,
your own involvement in either your
uncomfort in it is of importance,
but it,
I mean,
I wouldn't want somebody to say I'm
totally into this because I'm fighting
for myself.
And that's it.
In fact,
by the way,
sorry,
since you mentioned it on some of this
stuff,
on the Islam stuff,
for instance,
actually the first warning sign to me
was not a treatment of gays was dreamed
of Jews,
which I became sort of increasingly
noticing there was a problem a couple of
decades ago now.
But,
um,
and it was that,
how are you,
how are you seeing in British system?
I was,
I was worried about it because
started to notice that there were things
that were being said that I thought
wouldn't come around again and uh,
I'm not Jewish myself,
but you can,
you can notice these things and um,
and not need to as it were,
have a personal vested interest in,
in it,
you know,
and I mean,
as opposed to one other thing I'd say
about is I,
I generally think,
I mean,
the atomization of society into groups
with different interests is one of the
things that's causing the,
all this mess in America at the moment.
Um,
I don't see why the job of gays should
be just to sort of fight for the gays
and the job of the Jews would be a fight
for the Jews and,
and so on and so forth.
Uh,
I think,
I think the idea was sort of looking out
for each other's shortly,
the point in a republic.
And yet that point seems to be lost,
right?
So is that where this,
this intersectional crew has really lost
it because they are sort of getting what
you're saying that we should be looking
out for each other that should bring all
of these minority groups together,
except instead of that they're vying for
most depressed,
uh,
and most ridiculous and most
hyperventilating and all of that.
But the intersectionality people,
I mean the two big things,
one is they are the prime culprits of
this thing,
of the myth of Solvability,
the myth of humans eligibility.
If we just,
if we get the Rubik's cube right and
okay,
the Games get that and then we get the
traumas and then the people to hand them
the nonbinary in this and
exactly think exactly the same and speak
in exactly the preferential order that
we're loud speaking.
It will all be fine.
Whereas my view is you'll still have
every single problem of the world ahead
of you.
You'll still have to work out what your
foreign policy is.
A whole load of stuff is coming.
But.
So that's,
that's the first thing.
But the second thing is they are
obviously apart
in American society.
I don't think that's too much of an
exaggeration because they started at the
universities and it's trickling across
everything else and I've been having
really interesting conversations with
people about this in recent years in
Europe as well as in America and one of
the things I'm sort of slightly
confident about here in America is it
you do have an answer to it and it's an
answer you've had before.
You know,
the problem of the identity politics
thing is we're already starting to see a
the apart from being wrong in itself and
I think morally suspicious.
I'm selfish.
You can't stop what you're going to
create on it.
You can't have racial rights for every
group and racial pride rights,
every group and always hold back white,
you know,
pride,
whatever.
You just,
you just can't.
At some point it's going to break.
You can't keep bashing heterosexual men
and not expect at some point that
there's going to be some kind of
response.
So if everyone's allowed their group
apart from the majority or whatever,
then at some point that's going to get
nasty and I can see it coming so
clearly.
We see it now and it's already started
and um,
the thing is that in America you had the
answer to this,
which is what Tocqueville a mentioned.
It's the deal of being in the republic
is you don't do that.
You,
you deal with each other face to face to
face as a citizens.
You don't,
you don't do it as just people coming to
hawk,
something in the marketplace,
but face to faces,
individual citizens in the republic.
And this,
this is the only way out.
Um,
but I think there will obviously be some
mania before you get back there again.
You know,
it's funny,
you get the,
may you get back mainly business our
may,
uh,
you know,
it's funny the way I do the show,
I try not to talk about individual
people too much because I'd always
rather focus on the ideas.
But as you're saying this,
I'm thinking of something very
specifically that Linda Sarsour who I'm
sure you're.
No,
I spent an evening with us also in
Brooklyn.
Really?
Yeah.
Can I,
I'd tell you,
we got on roaring.
Lee and I sent some territory that was a
bit of sexual tension in the room and
uh,
avoidable,
but no,
the,
uh,
the fact is actually she,
um,
we're asked to debate the CROC fandom
word Islamophobia at the Brooklyn Art
Museum.
And I like a challenge and uh,
um,
I think our mutual friend,
lion has.
Jada was also meant to be there,
but I,
but,
uh,
oh,
um,
various things happened.
The garland shooting happened and it was
decided that it wasn't safe a yarn.
I still did it and things.
But uh,
yeah,
the whole thing that they started off
with the other side sort of giggling
about the fact that they couldn't even
turn up,
you know,
it was all using it against her and as I
ions afraid of anybody
and yeah.
And I say yes.
I encountered him before she became,
as it were,
infamous,
and I thought she was a very nasty,
very bitter,
very on America.
And actually,
um,
uh,
I just say that because she,
she knows like all demagogues,
how to introduce herself and introduced
herself to sort of proud brooklynite,
proud American and a proud Palestinian,
et cetera,
et cetera.
And I thought an interesting order,
but it was clear that she sort of really
hated America or at least hates America
that exists currently because it was me
that ended up having to explain to the
audience that for instance,
the New York police don't just go around
persecuting Muslims,
you know,
it just willful misrepresentation of,
of the American authorities at every
turn.
So I thought she was very dishonest,
very unpleasant.
And,
but I mean I've come across her type all
my life.
Yeah.
And the only reason I mentioned her is
because of what you said previously,
which really was about assimilation,
that the whole point of America is to
assimilate.
I don't know if you saw that speech she
gave about two months ago where she
called for a g high and then suddenly
the left was defending the word gi and
the white supremacists in the White
House and all that.
But I thought the key part of it put
jihad aside,
put white supremacy aside.
The key part was when she said,
we're not here to assimilate thought
what a,
that is the antithesis of the American
project,
this amazing melting pot that we have
where we've done for the most part,
multicultural,
right.
Multiculturalism,
right?
Where Europe has failed in a lot of
ways.
And she was saying,
no,
absolutely.
And I thought that was more dangerous
than the others.
Absolutely.
Of course.
I mean,
yeah,
as you say about him,
he put aside.
Yeah.
The fantastical idea of what she was
suggesting was,
you know,
you sort of have a,
a jihad by kind of going and just really
in a struggling.
And I'm just struggling in front of this
Israeli.
I'm having a timeline.
Yeah.
Um,
that,
uh,
yeah.
This is,
this is what I recognize is the night we
met.
I mean,
she really doesn't like this country,
by the way.
I mean,
we will have a problem by that.
It was what you,
what you do about that.
Um,
uh,
it seems to me she's a sort of very
rabid sectarian sort of Palestinian
nationalist who happens to live in
Brooklyn.
I'm a,
but I mean really what you do about it
is that people identified that recognize
it and called it out 40.
It was what it is and they just aren't
very many people to do that.
So I mean,
you know,
we all take sort of baby steps on this.
Don't we know is you say,
you know,
you end up with a left or defending this
and actually why don't you just say,
look,
she's not speaking as a critic of our
society who wants to sort of mildly
improve it.
She's speaking as an opponent of our
society because she doesn't like it.
Now I've encountered this,
I say all my life and my opponents and
the very close enemies I've made in
Britain and across Europe,
a certain type of person of that ilk who
clearly as an opponent of the society,
they don't like it.
And of course,
among other things,
or you can do is point a to point out
then is to say,
you know,
amazing
your hair really,
isn't it amazing?
Yeah.
And that's the catch 22 of what we've
got in the west,
right,
where we're going to have to let in all
sorts of voices.
That's,
that's the beauty of this thing.
And it also creates a little bit of the
brand.
All right,
let's talk about your book.
First off,
I love the title,
the strange death of Europe.
I thought using the adjective strange
was particularly interesting.
Why didn't you choose the word strange,
not slow or a series of other things
that you could have used first is,
which not many readers will get to a
slightly known history textbook.
I've got strange death of liberal
England,
which described the decline of the
Liberal Party in the early part of the
20th century.
But there's no sort of,
isn't needed it,
it was.
No,
it.
Although there is a slight similarity.
Um,
yeah.
Is a really a viral thing.
Is,
is just.
It is odd.
I mean it's,
it's a curious way to go.
Um,
and I think if you'd have said to anyone
have one or two generations ago,
this will be what Europe's issues would
be in the 21st century that basically it
couldn't,
couldn't find any way not to just allow
the world to walk in and join them that,
um,
that,
those generations would have been
surprised.
And uh,
so yes it is,
it is strange.
It's a night,
but I tried to explain why and I,
and in order to explain it,
I tried to explain it from not just from
the,
you know,
the sort of firsthand accounts and the
statistics and all that sort of thing,
but,
but the deeper philosophical reasons why
this is happening,
I think that's lots of books do bits of
that,
but I want to just say,
look,
this is the whole overall picture.
This is,
this is what we're actually living
through and this is why.
Yeah.
So the subtitle is immigration identity
and Islam.
Uh,
does that order have any meaning to you
in the way you phrase those?
It,
Kelly?
I mean,
it,
it centers on the 2015 migration crisis
when Angela Merkel opened the doors of
Europe and,
um,
couldn't really find a way to shut them
again.
Um,
but they'd already been open for a long
time as I explained.
I'm no,
I mean it's,
uh,
these,
these are the three massive things that,
uh,
that,
that are preoccupying I think not just
Europe,
Europeans at the moment,
the immigration crisis,
whether publics of Europe just wanted to
stop all across the continent.
All the polls all show the same thing.
The public wanted to slow down or stop.
Uh,
so that's the immigration better at the,
uh,
identity bit of it is a very,
very painful thing.
Which,
you know,
people aren't very good at talking
about.
Maybe I'm not very good at talking about
it,
but I think it's just their underlying
everything.
What is this thing?
What is it a European who,
who can be European?
Can anyone be a.
and is Europe a home for the people
who've been in Europe or is it for
anyone in the world he wants to move in
and call it home is a very,
very big question.
These are big.
And then the third one of that is the
Islam,
but which I mentioned because it's
obviously the sharp has specified.
There's a,
you can have somebody move in.
I know you can have a Nigerian Christian
move into a,
um,
a bit of the south of England and uh,
they will have issues I bring as
everyone does.
They will have their own ideas as
everyone does their own culture that
they've walked in from and everyone
does.
Um,
but,
uh,
it would be the person of another
background for another community and
another faith who would be coming in
with the issues that are really starting
to northern Europe.
We,
um,
we find this very hard to talk about and
uh,
it,
it's getting easier very,
very slowly.
But,
you know,
our big worry is we've not been great on
the integration.
All of our leaders say this,
all the European politicians admit this
now,
but the bit that is worrying us is Islam
bit because I think there's now a
general awareness that may be this is
the bit we can't digest or we're finding
it unusually difficult to digest and
incorporate A.
I don't say it's impossible by the way.
I just think for all sorts of reasons.
It's proving very hard in May in the
years ahead proved far worse.
So I know that you often make the
distinction like most educated people,
you make the distinction between Islam
as a set of ideas,
as any religion is simply a set of ideas
versus Muslim as as possible.
In this case,
do you think that there is something
unique?
I mean this is always what triggers my
friends on the left.
If you say that there is something
unique about the set of ideas of Islam
that is different than the set of ideas.
If we just take the big three
monotheistic once that is different than
the set of ideas of Judaism or
Christianity or at least how their
practice I think is the more operative
part because you can look through all
the books and there's plenty of bad
stuff in the old testament.
Okay.
Um,
do you at the,
at the end of this,
do you believe that it's just
incompatible that this set of ideas is
incompatible with the set of ideas that
the west is trying to preserve?
I think,
I think unreformed Islam presents a very
significant values challenge and it's
probably not reconcilable if,
if we have,
as it were,
the Islam of,
uh,
most Muslim countries,
it's very hard to see how that's doable.
Um,
uh,
I think all of this is very painful,
isn't it?
Because first of all,
we live in any case in an age of
relativism already were for perfectly
good reasons.
Sometimes,
you know,
we sort of pretend there's all sorts of
the same,
you know,
like I,
I might be a Muslim,
you know,
you might be a Christian,
she does yoga and it all comes out in
the wash.
Pretty much the same and I just think
that to begin with,
that's obviously not true.
I mean it's very strange to,
to want to concentrate on everything
other than the premises and origins of a
belief structure.
Um,
and as I've often said,
stop me if I've said this to you before,
but I mean,
you know,
there are all sorts of problems in the
Christian religion and in Christian
history,
but as I've often said,
you know what,
I'm just carrying out the thought
experiment that instead of getting up at
the sermon on the mount and saying,
you know,
love they neighbor and you know,
forgive me,
we're endlessly.
Jesus had said,
if your brother offends you,
chop his head off.
Would Christianity's history have been
more bloody or less bloody.
I think we'd all agree it's going to be
more and find the job behind the tree.
Yeah,
if Jesus had gone,
but if Jesus had gone into the whole
like,
fine,
you know,
the behind the train slaughter him,
um,
whatever the context,
right?
And then there would be even more
Christian antisemitism and then there
has been historically.
So I just think these things matter and
all this is very,
very painful for reasons that I go in
during some depth in the book,
which is that in recent years we,
in countries like Britain and I think in
America have had the luxury of sort of
describing ourselves in terms of,
among other things have been universal,
but what we have,
it should also be universal.
Now this is a very big,
this is always a debate within
liberalism of course is liberalism,
something we have or something we,
as it were,
expound and,
and,
and expand.
Um,
and in recent years I think that a
certain moroseness has landed across
Europe,
among other things,
uh,
because of a growing awareness.
Maybe what we have is very unusual and
that we have become disassociated from
the roots in which,
what we enjoy a group and this,
this is a problem.
There's a,
uh,
German uh,
legal ferris,
I quote in the book,
who puts this as one of the central
conundrum for Europe.
Is it possible?
Is it possible that the thing we're
enjoying and living through a can
survive without the connection to its
roots?
And I,
I believe that the roots of the West and
of Europe in particular fairly clear and
it's a combination of things.
It's the inheritance from ancient Greece
and ancient Rome.
It's obviously the inheritance of the
Christian civilization that washed
through the,
throughout the continent.
And then the refining fire,
the enlightenments and skepticism and
all these things.
And of course we would go on endlessly
about the other things that have added
to it.
But broadly speaking,
that is what made Europe Europe and what
made a European a European.
They breathe this,
this,
uh,
um,
but,
but the sort of the last man at the end
of that,
which I fear modern Europeans are,
is,
is in this strange position of I'm
finding it hard to even identify where
he and she has coming from,
let alone being able to return to those
roots and nurture them.
Because we all have,
I have,
I'm sure you have a conflicted set of
views about this,
um,
you know,
is it necessary for other people to
believe those of us who had,
who,
who have sometimes been tempted to hope
that,
for instance,
skepticism is enough constantly a
depressed by the discovery that for
instance,
somebody may be a free thinker about God
and that's it for free thinking point of
view.
Yeah.
From then on it's tribal away and um,
you know,
we're all,
we're all living through this,
but it's for Europe.
I think that the combination of a
historically unprecedented move into
people in the continent at the same time
that this sort of breakdown of what we
are ourselves is going on is a,
is a fatal,
fatal thing.
So there's a lot there that I want to
hit.
But I was what you said right at the
beginning,
which is that if Islam,
if unreformed or not allowed to reform.
So I think that's particularly
interesting for the space that you and I
sort of exist in because I've many
allies who are reformers.
I'm not just so I have allies that are
ex Muslim,
I have allies that are Muslim and many,
many people that I've interviewed that
you know,
but they're are treated horribly,
horribly and there and every time
they're allowed to get a platform or
it's actually by the evil conservatives
were all the things that people who
don't like me,
you'll say about me or say about you or
any of that stuff that makes the job a
good jillion times harder.
I say in the book towards the end when I
tried to rouse myself some
prognostications about all this,
that this is the worst possible sign.
I'm not just that the people that we
might talk about in these terms are so
few and between us,
you and I might have them in our phone
books.
Not just that,
but who were the ones that are most
under,
under pressure and under risk.
They really are the,
they're the good guys to say that this
is a tragedy for Islam is obvious,
but he's always been my view that we
should try to avoid making ourselves a
casualty of Islams,
civil,
internal strife.
And,
uh,
I think we haven't done that.
I think we've spent recent decades
almost deliberately running towards the
fight.
Didn't need to involve us so that the
tragedy of Islam becomes the tragedy of
the West as well.
I hope this could be avoided,
but I think it calmed.
And I think that as I say,
the worst possible sign for the future
is that it's a,
you know,
having dabbled summit in Germany who
lives under protection measure no wise
who comes in for the grief in the UK.
It's a young cle who followed the Dutch
integration ideal more than anyone who
ends up having to leave Holland.
These are very,
very bad signs,
you know,
you can still live openly as a,
Hammer has military commander in London.
Your life's fine.
You'll be celebrated in some ways,
right?
I mean this is a huge trump.
All right,
so let's,
let's knock out each one of these words.
We've sort of hit that I think a bit of
each one already on the immigration
front when you said that Merkel just
opened the doors.
I see a lot of different stuff written
about her that she either intentionally,
you know,
you get sort of the conspiracy people
that she wanted to destroy Europe or she
hates her own country and all this
stuff.
I try not to impune everyone's motives,
but when this happened in 2015 and there
was this combination of refugees and
immigrants and migrants and nobody could
figure out what was happening and we saw
videos of people just thousands of
people just running across borders and
all of this stuff and an odd amount of
them that seemed to be men in their
twenties and not women and children and
all that,
which implies that they're often
migrants looking for work and figures in
the front takes.
The majority of the people became in
2015 have no right to be in Europe,
which is,
which is fascinating.
And somehow,
even if you say that you'll be labeled
whatever,
but what do you think her intention was
in 2015?
This is why I tried to go back to the
beginning,
not just with history but also with the
philosophy on this.
Um,
I don't impute,
you know,
terrible motives to her.
I think she was blackmailed by history,
was facing a truly terrible humanitarian
crisis,
which was undoubtedly going on and I
said this in the face and I travel
around and speak to many,
many migrants from all over the world.
I've been to many of the countries they
fled from,
but I also go to speak to them in the
countries that they arrive into and
speak to them in the camps and certainly
have met and listened to more migrants.
And I think any of my critics,
um,
but,
you know,
it's,
it's easy to,
uh,
to exaggerate the ease of the situation
that she faced or the ease of the
solution to it.
And,
and I think that shouldn't be done.
It was a genuine crisis.
It remains a genuine crisis and the
biggest imaginable moral question.
Um,
so we also know that at the moment that
she made the decision in 2015 to
basically suspend all border controls.
Uh,
I suggested in my book,
but since my book has come out,
it's already now being confirmed by
somebody who was with her at the time
that what happened and in particular was
somebody said to Merkel,
we cannot have German border guards
repelling migrants and the photos go
around the world,
right?
So this is just condemned because of
history.
It's what is what a one friends for us,
because the second career of adult
Hitler,
it's an ugly way of looking at it,
but it's,
it's not entirely implausible.
Uh,
this is,
this is just,
this is another go around this terrible,
terrible history and past.
But,
uh,
you know,
it's not conspiracy.
I show in the book how much.
It's more what we call in England,
cockup.
I've always tended towards a cookout
view of history because if you see
politics up close as I have done quite a
bit throughout my life,
um,
you know,
that it's not really people pursuing
grant sort of schemes.
Really.
It's people who haven't done the job
before because you can't and there is no
qualification that gets you in position
beforehand.
Um,
and trying to deal with not longterm
things,
but tomorrow morning's headlines and
media reaction the next day.
And they,
they,
they drowned below the surface of this
babble.
That's how politics happens these days.
Right?
Which is not the way that both sides
talk about politics they wanted,
they want to make it seem like the other
side has constantly this grand plan and
everything's going according to plan.
Or as I said in the book,
the um,
every single thing we thought would
happen didn't happen.
And nothing that has happened was
expected.
I'd go back to the fifties,
you know,
the guest workers who were the first
people who came in after the war of
first migrant waves into Europe from
Turkey and elsewhere as Merkel herself
said in 2010,
we expected them to go home.
Incredible mockup.
Yeah.
Uh,
but then we expect them to go ahead and
then it didn't.
Of course,
they,
they wanted having tasted first world
economics and among other things they
wanted to bring their families.
And of course,
and if you have your families,
you have children and you enter the
schooling system and then you'll need
healthcare and then you'll need it isn't
element,
especially if the state's giving you a
lot of those things.
And uh,
and that's why we are where we are,
where we are,
where,
um,
uh,
you know,
the 2011 census identified people who
call themselves white British on the
sensors as a minority in London,
minority in 23 out of 33 London
burroughs.
It's why all the demographic projections
from across the continent,
um,
show Europeans,
uh,
I think not to overstate it,
losing the place they had to call home
or at least becoming a minority in it.
And this,
you know,
there are some people talk about that in
the,
in the sort of language of a,
Haha,
the empire strikes back,
now you're getting a taste of it.
You went round the world and now the
world's come to you.
And uh,
among other things,
I warn those people,
just be careful of that language,
the language of punishment.
Because if the language of that is,
as it were,
the punishment for colonialism,
then down the road you'll create a
movement will say,
well,
we managed to end colonialism.
Yeah.
And then they'll come for you to no
matter no matter what you do.
So with that being said,
so the identity part then is,
is really inextricably linked to this.
When you see the sort of what seems to
be the rising white identity and
movement or European identitarian
movement or,
or whatever,
what do you,
what do you make of it?
Do you view it purely as the natural
reaction to this?
Is there anything legitimate out of
that?
Are there parts that are not racist or
is it truly based in racist?
I'm,
I'm very,
very worried about this moment.
I have to say very,
very worried.
Um,
if you have people saying,
I'm proud of the color of my skin
because it's just skin color.
Of course there'll be some people who'll
do the opposite.
I am.
Somebody said to me the other day and
then it's,
the question is,
are you proud of being white?
And I said,
no,
of course not.
Why would I be proud of pigmentation?
But I then turned around and said,
no,
but I'm,
if you asked me if I am proud of my
coach,
I would say of course,
but it's something else.
And that I,
I,
um,
it's not really about pride and the
couch,
I,
some years ago I wrote a piece about
this for book the Prime Minister Gordon
Brown was editing on Britishness.
And I said,
I didn't think of these things in terms
of patriotism.
I think it would,
in terms of gratitude.
I feel gratitude before I've been lucky
enough to be born into A.
I'd love it if other people who wanted
to be part of it became a part of it.
And I think they can and I think it
shouldn't be and can't be racially
exclusionary.
I mean it's madness,
but it's a madness.
It seems to me that some people will be
falling into by being pushed and by
being ignorant and,
and other things.
But you know,
I come back to this thing,
there will be some people who will,
and I've,
I've found this a lot in conversations
across the continent in the last year or
two,
there will be people who will grab a bit
of the identity thing for themselves,
for tactical reasons.
We will get to this goal and we'll use a
dishonest tactic just like you're using
it.
Yeah.
And there'll be other people who will
say,
no,
it's not just a tactic is what I,
it's what I feel is what I believe.
Um,
I just strongly urge people not to go
down that route,
strongly urge them not to go down the
route of identifying by an accident or
skin pigmentation.
But to say if you,
if you want to talk in terms of values
and in terms of civilization and of
culture,
you cannot make it exclusionary like
that.
But the point about this is it's you,
that,
that can only be that it's the,
as it were,
white young guy who's told that you've
also got to tell it to the angry young
black demagogue who's telling people
have their own skin color to isolate and
congregate around around race.
It's got,
it's got everyone's got to,
you know,
to,
to make the deal as it were on this,
um,
but I just am filled with,
with,
you know,
concerned about this
and that probably has a little something
to do with the word strange because it
seems to me that it's possible that the
ship has already sailed on this perhaps
more in Europe than in America because
you guys had an integration problem
already from,
which is finally being acknowledged now.
But then you also have this new set of
people.
So even if everything was fantastic with
all the people that were there and all
the integration before 2015,
what do you even do with just the new
set of problem?
Let me give you an example.
By the way,
the,
um,
uh,
in Scotland there's a exists small
amount now,
but a Catholic Protestant mainly
centered around football supporting
Celtic Rangers.
Uh,
we,
they go by a religious affiliation still
still.
Yeah.
That's because of a movement of
Catholics from Ireland and Scotland a
long time ago.
Yeah.
Let me give you another example.
I had a very dear friend who died
recently who was a brilliant,
very,
very brave man,
uncle Shawn Callahan,
who was a double agent within the IRA,
the troubles.
And He,
uh,
he got up to the top of the IRA command
and he was informing all the time to the
Irish state and saved many,
many lives.
Was an extraordinary,
extraordinary man.
Uh,
I wrote an obituary for him and others
of his friends did one of the most
negative.
In fact,
one of the only negative pieces of our
short was in the Boston Globe who
referred to him as a,
as a,
as a grass,
as somebody who,
after you've come out and written his
memoir,
came to Hawk them around America.
Not just selling a book on writing but
hawking a book.
Why would that appear in the Boston
Globe only because a very long time ago,
a large number of people from Ireland
arrived in this country and settled in
Boston and held onto their Irish
identity and some of them have held on
to a belief that the IRA,
a murderess,
murderess sectarian gang,
whereas where their people.
So all these centuries later,
um,
uh,
the attitude and the Boston Globe,
when a man who risked his life to save
many,
many other people's lives dies and he's
to attack him basically as a grass and a
snitch.
Okay.
That's the movement of Catholic Irish
people into America who on earth,
things that when you bring the entire
developing world into Europe,
including very,
very large numbers of young men from the
Muslim world,
that this is going to be sorted out by
next February.
Yeah.
You know,
or you know,
roughly this time next year.
So does this show,
you know,
I use the phrase lazy thinking a lot,
but maybe that's not the right way.
It shows an inability to think,
you know,
what you said about Merkel in 2010.
It's like,
well,
we thought they were going to leave.
That's not lazy thinking.
That's man.
Did you even think.
I mean,
you know,
it's pretty good in Germany,
if you let people in.
Is there ever been a self imposed group
of people that left a western country to
go back to Iraq?
I don't think so.
Very uncommon know
of course,
once people,
once people realize that the economics
works better in Europe,
doesn't in sub Saharan Africa,
of course,
of course they come,
but we.
I mean we're,
we're just so torn about this and I
think we have to rouse ourselves to more
than moroseness.
We're talking about it.
It seems to me because we were not sure
why on the.
I'm pretty sure why,
but as counselors,
we're not entirely sure why it should be
our right to keep anyone out.
I'm not here.
There's obviously an American.
America has a different issue.
Of course it's an American.
It's legitimate to say America is a
nation of immigrants.
It's not legitimate to say that about
Britain.
It just isn't.
Hasn't been delivered late 20th century.
A Nation of immigrants and they're very,
very static population.
Even the Norman Conquest,
the thousand years ago shifted the
population by about five percent in the
UK.
So,
um,
I understand that in America,
the whole thing to do with immigration
is a bit harder.
People feel they're talking not about
them,
but about you or me and in Europe,
that,
that is a bit of the case.
Now,
there are people who talk in those
terms,
but there's also.
There's also just this additional thing
of,
by what?
Right?
By what?
Would I be allowed to say?
Anyone can come.
Now,
I think there are all sorts of ways you
argue the law
matter shouldn't matter.
The difference between legal and illegal
is everything.
Look,
I'm not a Canadian.
Why is that?
Because we have a border.
That means that a Canadian has to obey
the laws of Canada and I have to obey
the laws of the United States.
People think that even in of itself,
but that's somehow controversial.
We,
by the way,
what a beautiful thing.
It's just been watching Justin Trudeau
have to face.
It's so easy for politicians in Europe.
We've seen a lot,
you've seen it here in America.
Canadians have seen it.
It's so easy to grandstand or this let
them in a open the doors because when
the effects happen,
hopefully you'll be out of power and
you'll be retired somewhere in a nice
area with lots of people like you,
which was your dirty little secret.
Okay.
He'll move to New Zealand or something.
Isn't that where they all moving in New
Zealand?
Um,
but,
but yeah,
Trudeau is on the qb sort of berated and
morally grandstanding.
And then of course when there's movement
of people from America across the
Canadian border,
uh,
they start to get worried.
A Bill Gates,
by the way,
at the beginning of the migrant crisis,
said,
gee,
that America should take in the same
proportion of migrants that year as
Germany to Germany took in an extra two
percent of its population in one year
alone.
Uh,
uh,
and Bill Gates said we should take in
the same numbers in,
in Germany.
It has Germany did in,
in America.
Uh,
well,
interesting enough.
Only a couple of months ago,
Bill Gates,
I did a reverse ferret on that.
Actually,
no,
he said he certainly in a set of remarks
that if Germany continues like this,
it's going to destroy it.
Well,
imagine if Bill Gates,
instead of being the world's richest man
had been in charge of anything,
uh,
then you'd have gone through what
Germany is going through and it would
have vastly outlasted him as this will
outlast Merkel and all of us.
So the issue,
it seems to me the two things that I can
point out,
one is demanding with our political
leaders in particular,
think through things beyond the two year
electoral cycle or the four year
electoral cycle,
or more importantly,
just more of a morning's headlines.
You might have a bad mornings news.
It's a lot better than fucking up your
country.
It's a lot better.
It really is.
And the second thing about this is we
have to develop the ability to have an
adult discussion about these things that
recognizes it's not between,
you know,
your,
for the migrants.
I'm against them or you know,
uh,
um,
your Churchill,
I'm Hitler,
your chamberlain,
your Hitler.
Just to have the discussion on
recognizing these are different opinions
about our future and the and the,
you know,
I say toward the end of the book that we
have the tools for doing this.
Aristotle showed us a long time ago,
this is just a competition between
virtues.
Angola,
Merkel very understandably felt the
human virtue of mercy to be merciful
towards people who are trying to come
and I say yes,
but there is another virtue competing
with that which is the virtue of
justice,
not just justice for the people of the
world wanting to come and have a better
life,
but justice for the peoples of Europe.
If you have the discussion on those
terms between competing virtues,
not doing good and evil right and wrong.
Churchill,
Hitler,
me,
good.
You not see,
then you might be able to get somewhere
and Mr Gresham,
but it's as if we've sort of wounded
ourselves before even starting at the
start line.
So as to people that try to engage in
that.
I think that's what we consistently try
to do.
And I see you debating all sorts of
people from every walk of life.
Yeah,
I have a promiscuous debating debate.
It basically everywhere,
everyone,
some people are like,
you know,
now in prison,
not because I had debated and so much
they were prosecuting it,
but I mean,
you know,
I've debated lots of people who I'm sure
you've sent a couple of people to mental
institutions for after they've had to
deal with your wit that it's not that.
I mean,
I definitely,
if,
if somebody is,
is,
uh,
out in the general public
and has a platform and they wanted to
be,
I've always had the view,
yes.
That's not sale debate anyone by the
way.
Sometimes people go,
oh yeah,
you wouldn't debate me.
I think you've got to twitter followers
and you're nuts.
Blue Fox on twitter.
You're like,
Xena,
warrior princess.
No,
that woman,
she really wants to debate.
I'm alright.
I think,
I think we got a nice holistic piece of
this year.
Um,
so I wanted to shift altogether to end
this on a,
on a,
something somewhat on lifting,
uplifting as someone that does all this,
that you speak about this stuff.
You deeply care about this stuff.
I,
you know,
I worry about this stuff constantly be
wowed me staring off into nothing in the
middle of the day and I'm literally
worried about the fate of the Western
world.
You know,
I,
I wish I was playing video games again
as much as I used to,
but yeah,
I lost you on the video game thing.
Yeah.
But what,
what do you do for fun?
What do you do to just forget all this
stuff and just enjoy yourself and be
human?
Oh Gosh,
I.
well,
I know you don't like this type of
question because this is.
Well,
I'm,
I'm careful about private matters.
Um,
I,
I'm very happily in a relationship with
many years.
A lot of my family.
I've got wonderful friends.
I see them a lot.
Um,
I to relax.
I mean,
I read,
I read all the time,
uh,
and not just good,
it's enjoyable,
but because it's just,
I'm just endlessly learning and thinking
and so it's just so stimulating
sometimes when you have that thing of
what I described as catching up with
true,
you'd always known was there,
um,
the thrill of recognition that you get
from reading that I think is harder to
find in video games or television.
All right,
so,
you know,
so I do a lot of reading
as I'll shift this a little then.
So what would you say more importantly
than that,
to the,
to the person that's watching this,
the type of email that I get all the
time,
the person that is just a regular
person,
you know,
working a regular job that sees these
problems,
that hears you,
that is not a bigot and is not a racist,
but he's genuinely afraid of doing what
you do every which is say what you think
that they're genuinely afraid of.
Just putting their thoughts out there,
be it on social media or be it.
It's getting to the point where they're
afraid to talk to their own spouses
about what,
what,
what could you say to somebody to give
them a little bit of a boost on that?
I tell you what,
the,
the water's not as cold as people say.
It really isn't.
I mean,
I'm,
it's,
it's hard.
This one isn't it?
Because if you,
there has been a lot of focus on the
negatives.
Certainly some of the things we're
talking about today in recent years and
there's a sort of growing feeling of
actually wanting to previous recent
inferior as a google guy is a
demonstration.
The more that stuff
happens,
the more that people keep down.
Um,
and um,
it's very hard to.
I mean,
you can't be brave for other people.
You can't tell other people,
you know,
speak up.
But,
uh,
I think we can encourage each other to.
I mean,
um,
you know,
sometimes people approach me in a sort
of just want to not use.
Must be pretty hard for you to live
good.
No,
it's great.
I'm like,
I have cocktails.
My friends,
I,
I go to concerts,
I read things I want,
I enjoy the music,
I love and,
and I travel where I live and I go all
over the world and we're not going to
get any extra security tonight already.
I hope we're going to beverly hills.
I think we'll probably be friends.
We pick a fight with anyone today,
but no,
I am A.
I mean it's either you sit up and
there's a sort of exaggerate.
Yeah,
that's why I'm asking you this question
because I do think it's partly in
people's mind.
You start speaking then you realize.
Yeah,
I mean somebody said some bad stuff
about me,
but I'm still here.
Yeah,
exactly.
So people,
some are quite a lot of the time,
young journalists and things saying you,
I'd really like to write this but you
know,
I don't know.
And all this sort of thing and you know,
get this.
Let just,
just see and just write it.
And um,
I mean no one ever awarded somebody for
a career in journalism the way they said
nothing over.
There are some writers in New York Times
you could,
you could say,
but um,
uh,
you know,
you just just,
just do it.
And if it does,
what?
I'm very lucky in that I've spent my
career saying what I think and being
able to earn a living precariously but
successfully and uh,
I feel like I can write for almost any
of the newspapers I want to write for
and almost all of them will have me.
And uh,
I love writing for the range of them and
I'm very lucky to do this,
but it's not like I'm,
it's not like that's rare.
I mean,
I mean it's,
it's still legal to say what you think
and um,
and so I,
I just hate it when people say,
I really admire you for saying what
you're thinking here,
what the hell do you do?
And,
um,
but he said it's only that we all,
we all get used to the idea and just,
sorry,
just one other thing,
which is just about you.
But I find myself more and more tolerant
of people's opinions,
just more and more tolerant of it.
I mean,
I see,
I see people driving themselves mad and
I just sort of thing.
I mean there are some things like if
somebody,
you know,
I discovered they were into,
kitty fiddling or something and I'd have
something to say to them,
but pretty much,
you know,
on politics and all sorts of other
things I find myself like,
oh,
that's interesting.
Why do you think that?
And um,
and you know,
it's fascinating and who would want to
keep all of that down and um,
you know,
as long as we agree on the parameters,
as long as we agree that,
you know,
we don't shoot on the beach hut,
which is obviously up for negotiation,
it seems at the moment.
But as long as we don't do that,
then what's the problem?
Just just speak.
They don't expect somebody else to do it
for you.
I don't,
don't,
don't siphon it off like it's a wing of
government,
like the free speech center.
This is for you to do for us to do for
everyone.
That's how you ended interview.
Douglas Murray is on the twitter.
He is.
I've just been informed via the
teleprompter.
You're a thousand followers away from
100,000,
is that right?
No.
You're monitoring this constantly.
Yeah.
Must have these.
I think we can get you there.
Should I do something like if I get
100,000
followers,
I'll do something.
What would you do?
I tend to know who received.
Discussing.
Well,
this guys head over.
Greg's right for more on Douglas.
Follow him on twitter.
He doesn't care that much,
but I want the man to get to 100,000.
It's Douglas.
Kay Marie.
Thanks.